el planeta a Merced de los elementos en
Perú el ciclón yacua devastado
poblaciones del Norte dejando muertos
desaparecidos más de 200 damnificados y
miles aislados es un fenómeno que no se
daba en el país de se hacía al menos 25
años mire Cómo estamos la vecina del
agua le ha entrado los desagüe dentro de
su casa no hay desagües donde pueda ir
el agua no hay lugares donde pueda haber
Sumidero donde el agua discurra qué es
esto estamos muy mal en California las
lluvias también han causado estragos con
desbordamiento de ríos al norte del
estado que han inundado carreteras e
incluso obligado a tomar previsiones de
Cara a una de las noches más esperadas
del año la de los premios de la academia
esperamos lluvia cada año y también
esperamos lo mejor al pronósticos de sol
para el domingo poca lluvia hoy y mañana
pero en la programación nos da la
oportunidad de probar el sistema y
prepararnos si realmente llueve
es una prueba mucho más sencilla que la
que están soportando varios países
alrededor del indicó el ciclón Freddy se
mantiene activo desde el 6 de febrero
deja más de 20 muertos entre mozambique
y Madagascar ha afectado a cientos de
miles entre zimbabwes zambia y malawi y
solo espera la certificación como el
ciclón más largo de la historia
fue declarado ciclón tropical hace 33
días hemos recibido Muchas preguntas
acerca de si es un récord o no la
Organización meteorológica Mundial está
preparando un comité de expertos para
evaluarlo
al norte del Atlántico muchas ciudades
se preguntan Dónde está la primavera
como sheffield en Reino Unido donde este
viernes han caído más de 33 centímetros
de nieve o Michigan en Estados Unidos
donde ha sido necesario palear la nieve
para habilitar el aeropuerto en Beijing
la contaminación se ha combinado con
tormentas de arena desde el desierto de
gobi para dejar a la ciudad envuelta en
una capa de polvo y la calidad del aire
tan empobrecida que es potencialmente
peligrosa para la salud y es que en el
mundo entero la mano del hombre agrava
la furia de la naturaleza